this video is brought to you by
Squarespace the all-in-one platform
where entrepreneurs can easily create
and customize their own personal or
professional website more on Squarespace
later in the video so hello and welcome
to another episode of biographics with
me your host Carl Smallwood and today
we're talking about Daisy and violet
Hilton the Siamese twins of Vaudeville
in the original article for this one was
written by one Larry holsworth
thank you beginning in the 1830s in
Europe the United States traveling
carnivals and circuses gain popularity
one feature of the traveling shows the
collection of Acts and displays known as
the sideshow usually separate from the
main acts of the show hence the name and
thus requiring a separate admission fee
the sideshows display what many would
politely call
Curiosities little people then refer to
as midgets were quite popular as were
bearded ladies overly obese people
heavily tattooed men and women which
would I guess I I'm a heavily tattooed
man entertaining you guys such guess
that shows some things don't change eh
additionally slideshows were also
advertised wild men which were just
people born in exotic locales like
Borneo Tasmania or somewhere else in the
world that white people thought was
interesting or unique one of the most
popular kind of attractions that these
sideshows were conjoined twins commonly
known as siamese twins that they're
linked to that part of Southeast Asia
for the most part in the imagination of
the presenters back then they together
with their fellow performers many of
whom were fakes form what became known
as freak shows when Vaudeville and
burlesque theaters gained popularity the
freak shows accompanied them conjoined
twins particularly those who exhibited
other artistic talents became large
parts of audible acts in the United
States and Europe arguably one of the
most famous of these acts in the early
20th century were the conjoined twins
Daisy and vinyl Hilton no fun in
Vaudeville burlesque Carnival circus and
even a few films that acts included
musical performances with Daisy on
violin and her sister playing the
saxophone and dancing eventually both
sisters play saxophones and clarinets as
part of that act which it really sounds
kind of rad is that okay to say it just
sounds kind of cool we'll see like two
people like just shredding on the
saxophone while dancing like I kind of
want to see that and despite the immense
popularity they were ruthlessly
exploited and physically abused by their
owners it says that in the article
um that's not great who denied them
their own earnings kept them under lock
and key and subject to them to physical
and mental abuse there's the subtale of
exploitation abuse and unfortunately
does not end in Redemption
but most sources concerned that one Dr
James Ruth um mrcs assisted in delivery
of the Hilton sisters in Brighton
England on February 5th 1908 however in
his written account published in the
British medical journal a few years
later in 1911 Dr Ruth asserts that the
delivery took place before his arrival
was hissed by a nurse and a midwife
according to the aforementioned Dr Ruth
who reported on the birth of the girls
and subsequent development the Twins
were conjoined at the lower back and
buttocks that they shared a circulatory
system and a single rectum they were
otherwise strong and healthy he would
say and I quote they were fed for the
beginnings on diluted cow's milk as
their mother declined to suckle them Dr
Ruth also knows that their father was
dead though when and how the father died
is not known to history their mother
regarded the twins with revulsion
referring to them collectively as a
monster an unmarried by me described by
Rufus 21 tall and well-built the mother
called Kate Skinner affected nothing to
do with her children and allow them to
be bought by her employer Mary Hilton
from the point of sale the mother
retained no further contact with twins
that we're aware of and it's just weird
that you could buy kids but I guess it
was a different child buying time back
then the girls were kept in rooms about
the Queen's arms a bright and poor boy
and Mary found they could generate
income by selling tickets to the patrons
to view them she later moved them with
her to the evening star another Brighton
Pope jointly owned by Mary and her
husband their Guardians have the twins
take both music and dancing lessons as
they grew which were paid for with the
money they earned by Just Simply Having
people gawk at them in those pubs Mrs
Hilton insisted that the girls refer to
her as simply Aunt Mary while her
husband was to be addressed only as Sir
perhaps you ought to save the girls from
confusion over her husband's name some
sources claim she had as many as five
husbands over the next several years
though whether she was legally married
to them all or even any of them is
disputed when the girls fail to obey
I'll relax in their practice Mary with
them with the back end of the belt 1911
when the Twins were three years old Mary
Hilton took them on their first tour of
Britain advertising them as the United
twins this tour was so successful that
she followed up with tours of Germany
and the European continent the twins
eventually appeared in burlesque shows
and Carnival scishow sang danced and
played their musical instruments Mary
then took the twins on a tour of
Australia in Australia her own daughter
Edith met a Salesman and raconteur
called Maya Myers sometimes about Mayors
who married Edith and joined the
traveling Entourage doing what I'm sure
we'll find out
foreign
I'll take this opportunity to talk to
you about today's sponsor Squarespace
whether you are just starting out online
or you're an established veteran taking
the next step Squarespace provides an
easy and affordable solution to your web
design walls the first time that I try
to make a website for myself there was a
lot of complicated coding involved
Squarespace sidesteps this problem
completely by offering you a ton of
professional templates built for any
situation just choose one you like
customize the content and you are ready
to go
[Music]
you must be making his way through the
arrow trap corridor
if you're the kind of person who would
rather break the mold you can use
squarespace's fluid engine to go that
one step further if you want to add new
elements to your pages it's as easy as
dragging and dropping and then if you
want to customize those elements that's
only a few clicks away
I think he's found the lion pit once
you've set your website up you're
probably going to want to know how many
people are visiting here Squarespace has
a dedicated analytics page which can
tell you everything from where your
viewers come from so which pages and
keywords are the most popular you can
take this data and you can use it to
improve your website and you can also
figure out the best way to Market
yourself and your business or products
oh that's the Raiders themed Boulder Run
I wouldn't want to be Carl right now
head on over to squarespace.com forward
slash biographics Link in the
description and pin comment and use the
promo code biographics to save 10 off
your first purchase of a website or
domain
I'm gonna guess that by now he's found a
way out
I probably shouldn't be here when he
gets back
[Music]
in 1915 after the success in Europe and
down under Mary Hilton the misers and
the Hilton twins traveled to the United
States where they saw entry at San
Francisco at first they were denied
deemed medically unfit by immigration
authorities Maya Meyers no stranger to
the value of publicity stood up support
among the city's newspapers his rules
works and the twins were soon performing
in the San Francisco stages they
embarked on the tour of the United
States before eventually settling in San
Antonio Texas Mary Hilton died in 1919
in Birmingham Alabama according to most
sources though as with anything
regarding the twins outside of their
court documents there are conflicting
reports much of their backstory was
invented by their promoters as was Conor
the case with many Sideshow acts at any
rate Hilton's will bequeath her
ownership of the twins to Edith and Maya
Myers the girls were then 11 years old
and unaware that bequeath the ownership
of human beings was illegal in the
United States you got that in the end
guys as their Fame grew so did their
appearance fees that they were able to
command and according to some sources
they were made upwards of five thousand
dollars per week in the mid-1920s
roughly eighty six thousand dollars a
week in today's money a 1924 R20 San
Antonio Express described Violet and
Daisy as a strikingly beautiful highly
educated in book law and history and is
refined as any other two young women in
the universe yet despite their stardom
and the fabulous sums of money they
commanded they remained under the
complete control of the Myers with no
money of their own and no say of what
was in their act or when it would appear
while touring in carnivals various acts
which made up the play bills often held
Gatherings after the performances in
which the performances relaxed and
entertained each other though Daisy and
violet will usually invite such events
their managers refused to allow them to
attend Maya's considered the carnival
performers disease and mentally
deficient he kept his charges isolated
from their fellow performers to prevent
them from being and I quote corrupted to
such elements then purely by chance they
encounter the world's most famous
magician who was working in Cleveland
and Ohio
in the 1920s Eric Weiss achieved
worldwide Fame as a magician under his
stage name Harry Houdini such was his
Renown that he's often marked as simply
as Houdini and he exploited his skills
and Illusionist and escape artist by
exhibiting seemingly impossible escapes
while suspended from buildings or locked
into trunks or other devices submerged
in waters no handcuffs could hold him
and for him straight jackets were simple
to get out of as an ordinary shirt
Houdini accomplished these Feats of
magic and Escape through extraordinary
control of his muscles his breathing his
internal organs and most importantly his
mind throughout his life he practiced
mental exercises which helped him keep
himself calm and focused on whatever
task he faced oblivious to distractions
his skill at mind and body control
allowed to hold his breath for seemingly
impossible lengths of time examples of
the things Houdini could do include
wiggling out of a straight jacket while
suspended by his ankles from a pole
mortal stories in the air without regard
to the danger his presence of Mind was
according to his own Memoirs the key to
his success Houdini had first
encountered the Hilton sisters when they
were being exhibited as Curiosities in
Glasgow Scotland at the age of three
string of audible tour in 1925 Houdini
appeared in Cleveland at The Palace
Theater the Twins then on their first
Vaudeville tour were appearing next door
at the Cleveland Lowe's theater
remembering them from Glasgow Houdini
attended one of the performances after
which he called on her sisters backstage
he continued to visit them for the rest
of their engagement however the two acts
found themselves in the same city
thereafter he called on the twins
despite the approval of Maya Myers when
Houdini met the Hilton sisters he took
immediate interest in their personal
lives and well-being he had the
advantage of being the highest paid
performer in the world at a time no
theater owner at the time dared to
antagonize the great Harry Houdini which
made him impervious to the
remonstrations of the sisters
controllers Houdini taught the sisters
how to exist in their own separate World
rather than being constantly part of the
world they're over twin Daisy later
wrote of Houdini and I quote if we could
have our choice of our fathers we'd pick
Harry Houdini the magician taught them
to separate themselves from each other
mentally and spiritually as well as
emotionally both sisters later claim
Houdini gained the gift of a type of
freedom from each other through the
exercise of mental and emotional control
uh
later in the same Vaudeville tour that
saw the twins becoming enamored with
Harry Houdini Daisy announced to a New
York reporter that and I quote we're
both engaged but we won't get married
for three years at least the Twins were
17 years old at the time to whom they
were engaged was not specified but it
was likely nothing more than a teasing
of the reporter both Edith and Maya Maya
supposed any romantic relationships for
their charges if Daisy should give her
hand to some worthy young man a
complication would arise that would be
extremely embarrassing to her sister
Violet Edith was later quoted as saying
while on the road and at home in San
Antonio the Twins were forced to sleep
in the same room as Edith and Maya's on
the watch at all times their appeal to
Vaudeville audiences led to other
up-and-coming acts to Lobby to appear
with them one such act features a pair
of dancers and comedians George bines
and Leslie Town's hopes who call
themselves The Dancer mediums which is a
fantastic name why have I never heard of
someone describe themselves as a dancer
medium that's so money hope described
dancing with the twins as follows at
first it was a funny sensation to dance
with siamese twins they danced back to
back but they were wonderful girls a few
later Leslie Town's hope changed his
name calling himself from then on simply
Bob Hope wow that's a pop quiz question
I didn't know the Bob Hope like I was
gonna say small world but I don't know
Bob Hope which is kind of strange to
think like you know legendary comedian
Bob Hope was dancing with siamese twins
in a freak Show just makes the world
feel a little smaller don't you think
they were looking for ideas for a
mansion to be built using Daisy and
wireless earnings to serve as their
residents in San Antonio they finally
found one in Springfield Illinois which
has been designed by noted Architects
Frank Lloyd Wright in the Mansion they
had built they copied some of Wright's
design incorporate ideas of their own
and moved into the new house in 1927.
Daisy and Violet's earnings paid for the
house although we're not consulted on
its design Daisy and violet continue to
accumulate large sums of money for their
performances making them vaudeville's
highest earning performers in the late
1920s yet they saw little to none of
this money the Myers refused to even
allow the girls to go on a shopping trip
at home in San Antonio unless they were
escorted by one of their guardians or a
trusted underling in 1927 Maya's
petitioned a San Antonio courts running
a full legal guardianship on the basis
the girl suffered from an incurable
physical disability the petition was
ultimately granted
thank you
in late 1927 Daisy found herself the
object of desires of a fellow performer
a young singer named Don Galvin Myers
became aware of the attention as well
and warned Galvin against pursuing it
her first the singer complied but
nonetheless made the mistake of leaving
a vast with flowers outside of the twins
dressing room door coming with a note to
Daisy Myers found the vase first and
read a note and in a rage smashed it and
the flowers according to the girl's
Memoir from the guilty school what mines
are done they physically attacked him
the attack only ended when Edith pulled
the girls off her husband's back his
shirting tatters and his neck and face
scratched and bleeding following the
attack the girls were granted a
concession from Maya's henceforth they
would receive a percentage of money they
earned in the form of weekly payments of
500 into a trust fund he established for
them
he also agreed to let the girls travel
without his immediate supervision but
with hired handlers to look after them
fried of Maya's watchful eye the sisters
began to gain experience with members of
the opposite sex an experience which
seldom ran smoothly as you might expect
at one point in 1928 both girls were
infatuated with the same man Bill Oliver
who had been hired by Myers to look
after them and maintain their welfare on
the road oh man
it's never changed look at that
Hollywood
stays the same I guess girls falling for
the handlers like you can make this into
a movie this should be a movie Let's Go
sisters reporter became so jealous of
one another over Oliver that they
wouldn't speak to each other for days
which must have been incredibly awkward
given their circumstances each competed
with the other followers attentions
buying him expensive clothing jewelry
and even and REO Speedwagon automobile
in the end the relationship led to
serious trouble oh no oh no I don't like
where this is going
Daisy and violet continue to be leading
performers on Vaudeville stages in the
late 1920s they shared building with the
likes of Fanny Bryce Jack Benny Eddie
Cantor Sophie Tucker and other leading
stars of the stage yet Vaudeville itself
was in Decline the pressure from a
relatively new form of entertainment
Motion Pictures group many of the
leading stars of the stage were lower to
appear on the Silver Screen wardrobe
audience was decreased in size people
would spend their dollars on the movies
theaters which had formally offered only
live entertainment converted to movie
houses and fewer stages Beckham to
Vaudeville Stars the twins also found
direct competition in the fall of
another pair of conjoined twins Margaret
and Mary Gibb who offered a similar act
when considerably less money variety
magazine reviewed the Gibbs twins act
with a classical example of damming with
faint praise writing in Parts they're
playing a dancing pass as well as any
old one especially when not much is
expected with Vaudeville declining even
while competition increased the Hilton
sisters found their appeal to audiences
dwindling by 1930 the twins spent
increasing amounts of their time idle at
home in San Antonio with few bookings
though they did have seldom sold out
their earnings decreased noticeably then
in November 1930 the twins returned to
the front page of newspapers and
magazines though not in review to their
performances as it turned out Mr Bill
Oliver had been married and Mrs Oliver
was non-soo please and then name the
twins in an alienation of affection
suits she demanded damages of a quarter
of a million dollars
the lawsuit which named both Daisy and
violet and accused them of using their
whales and deceits led to luried
headlines to say the least the Kansas
City Star described the case as a
four-sided love triangle all those were
astounded that Oliver could make love to
one sister while maintaining good
relations with the other one columnist
lauded Oliver's clear gifts for
diplomacy Myers would like to
acknowledge that the accusation of the
suit were likely true yet he still
considered it little more than a
Shakedown the Scandal lived in the press
for much of the 1930s and the public
perception of the Hilton sisters changed
they became less favorable in the eyes
of the public and the sympathy they had
once engendered was replaced with moral
condemnation but as the fickle publicies
want to do opinion change once again and
this time the moral outrage been
directed towards Maya Myers and his wife
Edith the lawyers hired to defend them
in the lawsuit learned of the vast sums
the twins had earned and the manner in
which the mizers controlled them the sex
scandal was supplanted by an arguably
juicy one featuring theft abuse and
exploitation of the disabled in 1931
with the support and urging of Harry
Houdini the sisters sued their man
managers and legal Guardians Maya's
responded to the suit with Pious Blaster
saying and I quote my wife and I have
tried for 14 years to take the girls all
places possible constantly taking them
to theaters dancers and other places he
claimed and again I quote but they can't
fit in with that kind of life and they
should realize it Edith was equally oily
stating in part again they don't seem to
be making any allowances for the time
I've spent with them constantly caring
for them and attending to their wants
she would later tell the San Antonio
light I have spent the best part of my
life in their interests and now they
ignore me she later added why they
didn't even send me a Christmas card
yeah
because you suck a trial held in San
Antonio revealed the extent of the
wealth accumulated by Myers and Edith
Myers at the expense of the twins the
Myers held stocks Bonds in an extensive
portfolio of Texas real estate purchase
with the money earned by Daisy and
violet none of which was in their names
a sensation in the local newspapers the
trial included testimony by Myers that
he had never struck the twins in any
manner testimony refuted by the sisters
on the witness stand Violet testified
that the twins had been treated as
prisoners to the point they were not
even allowed to attend church she would
say we were taught to do our praying at
home and you know what if you want to
get the sympathy of a jury in Texas
that's the way to do it
well played violent well played the
lawsuit was settled in the sister's
favor the earlier sex scandal suit was
settled as well the sister's emerged
from the courts in 1931 fully
emancipated in control of their own
earnings and with a hundred thousand
dollars in Damages to boot about two
million dollars in today's money
assessed against Myers and Eve Myers the
real property they are paid for remained
in the hands of Myers and Edith the twin
celebrator returns of Vaudeville as the
Hilton sisters review
thank you
now Italian Violet and Daisy returned
performing in 1931 Vaudeville was all
but debt they found their audience in
the burlesque theaters and concert halls
and their earnings were substantially
curtailed from those of their Heyday
that's summer they went to Hollywood
where they appeared in the pre-code
title freak switch anyone who studied
film was no doubt watch because it's one
of those like incredibly fascinating and
compelling stories of its like you know
creation and uh response to and the
subsequent censorship and response from
the media and audiences and like movie
industry itself it's a really
fascinating story that I'm not doing
Justice because I studied it like 15
years ago when I did my own studies if
you can look it up I would highly
recommend doing so it's a fascinating
tale among the unfortunates recruited
for the film where a woman known as lady
Olga the bearded lady a man born with
neither arms nor legs called Prince
randian and known as the human
caterpillar and a young man with no body
below the rib cage called the half boy
the twins largely ignored their fellow
performers during filming Willard
Sheldon a scriptwriter on the project
said of the twins in a horrid pun if
that's what it was intended to be they
stuck pretty much to themselves after
filming freaks the sisters returned to
performing in Burlesque houses and
theaters with steadily dwindling success
in 1936 Daisy became pregnant she
eventually gave the child up for
adoption while Daisy was pregnant Violet
married an actor James Moore Violet's
marriage lasted 10 years though it was
largely done for publicity and rumors
persisted that her husband was gay they
lived separately and eventually divorced
Daisy married in 1941 that marriage to
actor dancer Harold Estep lasted all of
10 days so I guess one sister always had
a one-upon the other one because that's
the guy sibling rivalry he's just a
thing this sounds like the most intense
sibling rivalry ever like they were
literally trial at bang the same dude
Daisy and violet remained in the public
eye largely due to gossip over their
relationships and sexual activities
Daisy told one report that whenever her
sister was entertaining she would simply
read a book or turned away to go to
sleep I can't imagine the the levels of
ego bruising that would happen for a
dude if you like try to give it your
best moves you sat there you're giving
it rizz and you just see the person
literally joined at the hip
um with your new beau just like reading
a book and be like are you done
that that's gonna suck the sisters
appeared in another film in 1952 chained
for Life Loosely based on their own
lives the film was poorly received
though the twins made live appearances
that it show ends where it was
frequently paired with freaks in a
double Bill the failure of their films
to draw audiences meant their live
performance were frequently unobserved
by paying customers
foreign
in the early 1950s the sisters tried
retirement from performing opening of
all things a small hot dog stand in
Miami Florida it too failed by the
mid-1950s the sisters were back on the
road this time performing a striptease
act in CD theaters and burlesque houses
going to Violet and I quote we made the
big switch to this sort of dancing for
two reasons money and fun mostly Fun by
then the Twins were nearly destitute
their previously earned Fortune gun in
December 1961 the sisters made their
last public appearance as performance
it's a drive-in theater in Monroe North
Carolina as they did so their booking
agent abscondered with their earnings
because of course you know like one last
kick in the ass before you know retiring
forever they were stranded nearly
penniless without the funds to return to
their rented apartment in Miami the
owner of the motel they were staying in
took pity on the sisters offered them
free rooms and dining people's years at
a nearby restaurant they owned and found
them work at a local grocery store he
also found them a more permanent
residence in a mobile home in a trailer
park outside of monreal the twins worked
as cashiers in a park and shop grocery
in a specially designed and built Booth
which accommodated them both allowing
each to service one lane of Shoppers
which admittedly is really good of the
owner so I'm British and like Folks at
home if you're like you're listening to
this and it's not cut out like is it
true that American cashiers just can't
sit down like this is a thing that we
always get over here of yeah like
cashiers get like reamed out for sitting
down on the job because it's lazy even
though their job doesn't require them to
stand up like I'm sat down right now if
I do this job still I'd hate it so it's
that thing like yeah and then you just
look back like you know nearly 50 years
ago like they made special
accommodations that allowed like you
know Violet and Daisy to like you know
work with some dignity and like you know
self-reliance understandably walking to
work each stage with the attention of
locals some of it unwelcome for the most
part the town support the Twins and
their customers their income was
sufficient to allow them to rent a small
home now last year's thus passed in
relative obscurity far from the
Limelight when they spent most of their
lives in December 1968 the Twins were
stricken with influenza during The
Season's outbreak of Hong Kong flu on
January 4th 1969 after twins had not
been seen for several days the police
conducted a welfare check the sisters
were dead Daisy having succumbed first
Violet following two to four days later
they were 61 years
that funeral was sparsely attended with
most of the mourners and all the
pallbearers their fellow employees from
the parking shop the twins who had once
commanded as much as six thousand
dollars per week in salary left behind
an estate with just about sixteen
hundred dollars after expenses their
home built by their earnings in San
Antonio still stands to this day and
although the sisters are still
celebrated there they long faded Into
Obscurity everywhere else and cheers for
tuning into this episode of biographics
like it had a bitter sweet ending but
not as bad as I was expecting from that
intro again the article that formed the
base of this video was written by Larry
holsworth find links their socials below
no doubt I am your host Carol Smallwood
thank you very much for tuning in links
to my stuff will be found below I've got
a channel called Flat fiend as well as
being the interim host for the other
sister projects two biographics
Geographics and top tens
um much appreciate everyone tuning in
and as always half the day you deserve
cheers